joining me now to respond is former
education secretary bill bennett
bill thank you so much for taking the
time to join me this evening
i am concerned about the direction that
we're going we've heard the trope of two
americas over and over again from
politicians but nothing like this past
year and the experience under this
divided rule has made us reach this
point like anything before in my
lifetime
how do we get back to not being a house
divided
well we're getting back by the way nice
pedigree house divided matthew 12 25 to
abraham lincoln to ben dominic i like
that
that's a nice uh that's a nice line of
succession you're in ben
uh we are getting back we're fighting
back we're waking up
we were dazed uh we were knocked against
the ropes uh we weren't sure what hit us
and as you point out in the early days
of covet we didn't know what to do we
weren't sure about this
now we've learned a lot
you know vaclav havel and other great
statesmen like lincoln our greatest
statesman crisis of the house divided uh
hovel said
you know we were living a lie in the old
communist czech republic old communist
country he said because
they wouldn't let us live the truth
because if we lived the truth
they would all know that it was a lie
and everyone would then act
and so it was important to suppress the
truth
uh hovel rights and so we've seen the
effort ben to suppress the truth through
some of these high-tech
operations uh and elsewhere
but what we need to do it seems to me
more than anything else ben
is engage in what the author novelist
tom wolf called the great relearning
we have forgotten some of the first
things
that we need to now remember
that schools are there to teach children
how to read and write and count and
think and by the way the children come
first not last they've been a very
neglected group over the last couple of
years
second that we're a sovereign nation we
have borders and they matter
third that with the protection the
government offers to every citizen
safety is the first object to government
federalist papers say
comes freedom and freedom for those
individuals the american people are now
waking up
i don't know if loudoun county virginia
will be you know the the lexington and
concord of of this
revolution
but things are stirring and i think i
think the great relearning is taking
place the american people are saying
we're not taking this anymore we don't
believe you
i would like to ask you as a former
education secretary what you would say
right now to those families frustrated
tired who have learned in the last
several weeks that many of the school
systems that they were depending on
being open
sending their kids back to in-person
learning are even now entertaining the
prospect of being closed for god knows
how long you saw i'm sure the vote among
the chicago teachers union
you know in in terms of in terms of
virginia's arlington
schools similar things are happening
across the country what would you say to
those parents about what they ought to
do in such a situation
you know the first thing i would think
about is see if you can go elsewhere
if this is the kind the kind of regard
they have for you and your children
knowing the circumstance that puts you
in as a parent particularly a single
parent
and what this distance learning does for
most children
they must not have much regard they must
not have much regard
for you think about homeschooling think
about a charter school think about
sending your child elsewhere
again
we have seen the lie and the lie is that
we care more about your children than
anyone else no they don't if they did
they would be there and they would be
there
and they would be there in person
the one more thing i want to say is
there's a great essay by hannah aaron in
which she talks about a lot of things
one of them is surrender
there's a certain kind of surrender ben
we are not allowed to practice in front
of the young
we cannot surrender ourselves we cannot
surrender our liberty our freedom and we
cannot surrender them
find the best education you can for your
child that you can provide
hopefully the supreme court's on the way
with more decisions that will favor
educational choice and support
educational choice
so that money follows the student
wherever the student may go
this may be the educational shake-up we
need
but i do think the great relearning is
beginning i think it's beginning in
earnest when you talk to people around
the country citizens
those subjects are becoming citizens to
use your nice phrase there
i think you can see a sign of this and
people are tired of surrendering to the
experts
who have been so wrong
just one last thing when the when the
head of cdc says well we thought 10 days
for lock up you know uh would be proper
but we decided to go with five because
we think that's all that the public
could bear
well
that ain't science that's policy and
that's what they've been making all
along
absolutely thank you uh bill bennett for
joining me this evening hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else